foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
[ __ ] broke
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
we were gonna get his tax returns
just like we're gonna get his perp walk
eventually
goes on a rant and Rave about to
Twitter nipian the IRS
whatever the [ __ ] he's ranting about
they spot on my campaign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh same [ __ ] different diaper huh
no my God
some people are comparing the tax
returns to Nixon's tax problems that
Nixon had when he was president
now I don't know if you know this but
there's so many similarities between
Richard Nixon's problems and Donald
Trump's problems
but really honestly this country kind of
collectively even though you know
it's been a while motherfucker's dead
most people don't remember this [ __ ]
this country kind of owes an apology to
Richard Nixon I mean we got I mean we
kind of do you know like the guy maybe
shouldn't have been present maybe I
don't know
but at this point
at this point with this [ __ ] criminal
I mean he really has hey he really has
set the the bar for crooked really
[ __ ] high right
like even if we have a president that's
just a total [ __ ] box I mean a total
[ __ ] [ __ ] box committing crime all
over the place still may not rise to the
level
of this [ __ ]
so apparently the reason why the Ways
and Means Committee wanted the [ __ ]
returns in the first place
was that the IRS because of who Donald
Trump appointed was not doing
the normal audit of the president which
they always do
now this isn't difficult stuff right
like since Nixon speaking in Nixon
every president or person running for
[ __ ] president for that [ __ ]
matter
that any parties actual nominee releases
their [ __ ] tax returns several years
of them
to let the American people know that hey
I'm transparent right I'm gonna be your
[ __ ] leader I'm gonna make decisions
for you
know here here's my even Mitt Romney
did it
I mean you know we shouldn't have to
pass laws on this stuff
but maybe we have to
and every [ __ ] Presidential nominee
has done this
every president has done this and every
president undergoes an audit by the IRS
every [ __ ] year now most presidents
of the United States don't have problems
and the reason why is because they get
rid of those conflicts of interest about
their money when they become president
another good example is George W bush
[ __ ] was rich
[ __ ] was rich before he became
president of the United States he was
governor of Texas he had a lot of
conflicts of interest that could have
caused problems when he was president so
he put it in a blind dress same as Mitt
Romney
that's what they did as the nominee not
as the [ __ ] president but as the
nominee they did this [ __ ]
and all because of the trouble that
Richard Nixon got into with his taxes
now I don't know if you know the history
and and you know I just recently learned
that his tax trouble which is kind of
funny
when you look through the lens of the
crimes that we're looking through right
now
it's kind of funny
when Richard Nixon was the vice
president for Eisenhower and he left
office he took his documents with him
what he did was is he donated
donated those documents back to Nara the
National Archives
and he took him as a deduction on his
taxes
that's the the tax Scandal that Nixon
had
which was outside a Watergate by the way
every president has scandals every
single one of them
I mean Bill Clinton with Monica Lewinsky
George W bush
on and on it goes with him
Obama wore a tan suit
oh man
they're gonna choose him as their
nominee folks
they're gonna choose him I'm telling you
who the who the [ __ ]
is gonna say the [ __ ] that he's willing
to say to win their nominee to be their
nominee
and that's what they want anyways have
you been paying attention to Republican
politics lately
they absolutely
the bar is what is the worst possible
vile thing that you can say into a
microphone to gain support of a bunch of
white supremacists in this country
that's the bar
you don't think
this [ __ ] being a caged animal
being painted into this corner he's
gonna be indicted
trust me this [ __ ] is not
skating on this
not with the nail eater Jack Smith
it's not gonna happen
criticize me all you want you say well
where's the indictments he needs to be
arrested now
even even when he is indicted he's not
going to be arrested they'll arraign him
on the charges and they'll release him
it's what's going to happen
you're going to be really disappointed
if you think this [ __ ] is going
to sit in a jail cell waiting for a
trial
they're not going to do it
Justice isn't blind in this country
there's different tiers
and for sure Donald Trump has had a
different tier his entire [ __ ] life
and the other Rubicon that we have to
cross here is this stupid idiot is a
[ __ ] former president
which is the most ridiculous part about
the whole thing
that we actually put ourselves in a
situation in this country where we're
okay with this [ __ ] being the
head of anything
105 million dollars I think is what he
was in the hole one year
listen to me when I tell you this
a real billionaire a real one
does not have a loss
a total loss of a hundred and five
million dollars okay
it's not a [ __ ] thing he's not a
billionaire he never was
he's inept he's a [ __ ] buffoon
he's not always the con man he pretends
to be most the time he's the mark
he's gonna lose his entire company
and his entire washing machine here why
do you think he's doing the Trump
Trading Card thing he's got to find the
next [ __ ] the next [ __ ] Griff to
sustain him to get to the next one and
to the next one into the next one into
the next one
that's his entire business
we find out that The Apprentice was a
big part of his income and then it
dumped
but the thing we found out most is that
he was using the presidency
to suit his power to suit his own
interest
and that's why the Republicans will
nominate him you're like what whoa whoa
wait a second you're telling me his
crime and Corruption is a thing that
will get him the nomination you goddamn
right it will
it's a Republican party have you been
paying attention
Jesus Christ they got some bonehead I
don't know some [ __ ] District that
totally [ __ ] lied on his bio
the guy got elected he's not even who he
says he is Kevin McCarthy doesn't give a
[ __ ] because Kevin McCarthy needs his
[ __ ] vote
and it shouldn't be surprising I'm not
even gonna really talk about that story
to be quite honest with you he's just
another [ __ ] Republican
they're frauds they're phonies you think
any Republican has their bio correct
look at Jim Jordan Matt gatz Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bober for crying out
loud
you think these people are who the [ __ ]
they say they are get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
Donald [ __ ] Trump
get the [ __ ] out of here
hell make that guy the Speaker of the
House really I mean at least at least
the [ __ ] lied about every single
aspect
of his bio I mean [ __ ] at least he was
brave enough to tell a total [ __ ] lie
not [ __ ] people well I mean he's
bullshitting them but you know you know
what I mean
I don't know what the guy's name is I
don't know several people talked about
it several people messaged me about this
like he's just another [ __ ]
Republican
so who who he lied about who he is
Madison cawthorne okay
[ __ ] out of here
like we don't know that Republicans are
a bunch of [ __ ] phonies Ted Cruz Josh
Hawley Tom Cotton
come on Lindsey Graham lady G give me a
[ __ ] break
it is a prerequisite to be a [ __ ]
fraud to be in the America First Nazi
party
[ __ ] out of here
you want me to clamor on about some guy
who lied about his [ __ ] bio to become
a republican politician who's going to
be a one-termer you may waste my time
with that hell no what we're gonna do is
we're going to drive wedges between the
top
that's what we're gonna do
Kevin McCarthy is likely
to be the speaker
I I'm more convinced now that he will be
the speaker by the way
now that may change tomorrow
right now I'm convinced that Kevin
McCarthy
after a week of silver votes with no
speaker of the house he will get there
he'll have to give away a lot of his
speaker power
he will barely be a speaker
because he will give the majority of the
speakership to his caucus that's what
he's gonna have to [ __ ] trade away
because he's inept
he's a bonehead he's a [ __ ] loser
and more than anything they do not know
how to govern they have no [ __ ] clue
they have to sell their souls to the
devil
that's what they did with Donald Trump
and Kevin McCarthy will get to 218 I'm
sure of it
eventually
it'll be clear that they do not know how
to govern and won't be able to govern
but he'll get there
he's going to trade away a lot of [ __ ]
and one of the things he's going to
trade away
is investigating anything absolutely
anything
about Donald Trump in January 6.
absolutely anything
I will be frankly surprised if they do
this whole stupid investigation about
political prisoners to be quite honest
with you
I would imagine that in a house
Committee hearing not one Republican
will speak the words Trump
or January 6 in a negative way not
[ __ ] one
I mean they'll say hunter Biden a lot
laptop a lot
they're gonna say Twitter a lot they're
gonna say FBI they're gonna say deep
state
they're going to say a lot of queuing on
[ __ ] a lot of Q Anon [ __ ]
and they're gonna try to impeach Hunter
Biden's dick pics and all kinds of stuff
all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] but let them
let them
let them
they can't even wrap their [ __ ] minds
around the fact that their guy their
Mussolini Jesus
put acting people into the IRS to make
sure that the American public didn't
find out he was broke he doesn't care
about the crime if there's crime in
those tax returns he doesn't give a [ __ ]
I've been saying that for a long time
we've seen that for a long time and do a
microphone this [ __ ] doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the crime he commits
he thinks he's above it all he thinks he
cannot be held accountable just go look
at his [ __ ] deranged statements
he is scared
that people will find out he's [ __ ]
broke
that's what he's terrified of
and it's the truth it's been the truth
for a long time
[ __ ] does [ __ ]
billionaires do not do not ask
for [ __ ] donations like this
[ __ ] asked for him
to his personal political organization
and then more than likely uses that
money to buy a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
nft trading cards [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] money laundering scheme
by the way in the Trump trading guards
I'm sure of it
the evidence is going to prove that I'm
sure
but we don't have much time left
and the clock is [ __ ] ticking here
on Congress it's ticking
the good news is is that you
pro-democracy people put 51 Democrats
in the Senate who are caucusing in the
Senate because now we get three
independents
you know Cinema
Bernie Sanders and King
but they caucus with the Democrats
so that puts us at 51 which gives us
full subpoena power
in the Senate
so maybe that'll help with some
oversight because there's not going to
be any oversight coming from the
Republicans they won't even know how to
govern
they're going to shut down the
government in September
trust me
I will be at this microphone in
September of 2023 talking about a
government shutdown for at least two
weeks at least bare minimum two weeks
doubt me [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy has been working for weeks to
try to get to 218 and he has not been
there yet
you think you think that [ __ ] in-app
piece of [ __ ] is gonna be able to whip
up enough votes to keep the government
open [ __ ] no
hell no and you think he's gonna have
the courage to stand against Donald
Trump When Donald Trump wants the
government shutdown
because Donald Trump's gonna want the
government shutdown and Donald Trump's
gonna want to be able to say I made the
government shutdown because they listen
to me it's gonna be a huge huge year of
Chaos
and it ain't gonna be from anyone who's
pro-democracy
it's all going to be for the ones who
want to tear down democracy and it's
going to be clear for everyone to see
right it's not going to be hard I mean
we're gonna have to point it out we're
gonna have to yell and scream every
single day to keep people ramped up and
paying attention to this [ __ ]
right they're gonna get distracted by
baseball and then basketball and
football is going to start
so we really gotta stand around Jumping
Up Down waving arms going hey
you like all that stuff
you got to do democracy first
I don't think anyone's gonna challenge
you
not a [ __ ] soul
did you see the news of this texture
[ __ ] [ __ ] put people in
the IRS to make sure he wasn't gonna get
audited which is a normal thing for a
president to get audited
it's it's a part of what our government
does
and he made sure it didn't happen
and it definitely was not because of the
crime [ __ ] that you can't convince me
that he was trying to hide something for
Crime he doesn't give a [ __ ] hell he
crimes right out in the open
he talking about trying to hide crime
[ __ ] that
he does not want people know he's
[ __ ] broke and how broke he is
the other thing too is he doesn't want
people to [ __ ] find out his grifting
schemes to make it look like he's
[ __ ] Rich make it look like he's a
billionaire and shame on Forbes by the
way
what the [ __ ] is that scam
are you [ __ ] me are you ever gonna
believe the Forbes top 100 or whatever
the [ __ ] list of rich people ever I
am I am sure that the Elon Musk is not
even close to being the richest man
alive not even [ __ ] close not even
[ __ ] close that [ __ ] is so
leveraged he owes so much [ __ ] money
he's probably broke too
you can't you cannot you will not be
able to convince me of the richest man
in the world ever again [ __ ] nope
prove it what proof do you got
Donald Trump is on the Forbes list get
the [ __ ] out of here all them years no
he wasn't
it's all nonsense
it's all [ __ ] all Bluster all a
fraud [ __ ] Forbes in their list then go
to hell
with that [ __ ]
and again Elon Musk has never been the
richest man alive
I don't believe it now how could you
how could you believe that [ __ ]
he's desperate for money Elon well Trump
do
which billion real billionaires normally
aren't desperate for money they normally
don't have to go hawk you know a huge
percentage of stock in one company that
they own
to support another company
they normally don't have to do that it
seems like elon's running out of money
doesn't it if you're running if you're
running to your piggy bank
the thing that supposedly makes you
so much money Tesla
I mean Jesus Christ that thing is tanked
to half the [ __ ] value
and he's been the entire cause of that
almost I mean besides the fact that
those cars just [ __ ] catch on fire
boy a GM or a Ford EV looks better and
better doesn't it I mean I'm not there's
not as much fire data or combustible
data on the on the Fords and GMS but God
damn
I'm just saying
I'm just saying I I don't make money for
you know saying GM and Ford makes
better EVS I don't know if they do I'm
just saying
you're gonna go with the one that isn't
catching on fire I think I mean am I
wrong
I don't know I'd probably go with the
one that doesn't catch on fire if it
were me
I don't have an EB
yeah and maybe I will
I still buy the old gasoline
but this is the [ __ ] that we have to
deal with
right before the holidays
but here's the thing folks politicize
the [ __ ] out of it
you know what you you know what you
gotta say to your [ __ ] Maga
supporting Uncle Earl at Christmas hey
did you see tax returns he ain't no
billionaire he's [ __ ] broke because
you know Uncle Earl three years ago or
during the 2016 elections like well the
reason why he's so successful he's such
a successful business person he's so
rich that's why I want him to be
president he'll run the country like he
does his businesses
[Music]
you remember this stupid [ __ ] even in
2020 they were like oh he's done such a
great job just like he did a great job
in his personal business career [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here
people are delusional
but now you got the ammunition now you
got the facts right there they're in
front of you and they're gonna come out
with more there's there's more of these
these facts are going to be uncovered as
these these tax returns are evaluated by
people who know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about
and we'll we'll serve them up to you
here so you can set them up on the T and
knock them out of the park
with your Uncle Earl
but don't pass up the opportunity here
don't pass up the opportunity because
you ain't got every single fact about it
see that's the stupid thing that [ __ ]
liberals do too that that Republicans
always win on
is they wait to have every single
[ __ ] fact oh wait till we have all
the evidence to make a judgment [ __ ]
that [ __ ] he's broke you know he's broke
I know he's broke everyone knows he's
broke now we got the tax return to show
he's [ __ ] broke just say it just tell
Uncle Earl your dude is broke you
thought he was rich you thought he was
successful he's a [ __ ] loser
the one thing that you thought he was so
good at he sucks at
so [ __ ] Uncle Earl
[ __ ] Trump [ __ ] him
tell him how it is you don't have to get
out your [ __ ] phone and show them the
returns of the evidence let them let
them [ __ ] argue
about how unsuccessful this [ __ ]
is that's exactly where you need them
right and that's what we should be doing
every single day
I'm telling you wedges draw wedges he
will be the nominee
just go on that fact he will be the
nominee even if he isn't [ __ ] it we have
to pretend like he's gonna be you know
that right
even if he doesn't eat this out and
somehow he gets in all kinds of trouble
and Republicans just
and his support just leaves him
doesn't matter
doesn't matter we have to make sure that
we are prepared for that [ __ ] to
be the nominee
and I'm going to keep saying he's going
to be the nominee and that's mainly the
reason why but I I actually see a
pathway 100 he's a crooked [ __ ]
he's a fraud he's willing to say and do
anything he can for his own gain and his
own power what more do you need out of a
Republican
what more do they need than to make him
the nominee that's the [ __ ]
prerequisites right
don't you think or am I out of my mind I
don't think I'm out of my mind it's
Wednesday it's hump day and tomorrow we
have bonehead of the week Pole now you
know it's a special week because it is
the holiday week of Christmas and we're
going to be taking off Friday and Monday
so we're gonna have a four day weekend
we will not have a show
on Friday or Monday so I appreciate you
hanging tight with us as we take a
little break for the holiday but
tomorrow I think we're going to do a
little bit of a Christmas thing I don't
know maybe maybe not
but I I'm definitely going to try to be
in the Christmas spirit I'm going to see
if my co-host Gabe Sanchez
will be in the Christmas spirit
maybe we'll play some songs or something
something Christmasy you know
for the spirit
I think that's what we'll do but
tomorrow will be our last show of the
week and we will come back on Tuesday so
do not do not forget
and if you miss us on Friday or Monday
it's not because you missed us it's
because we are taking a short little
break and then we'll be back I am I'm
I'm actually kind of super excited about
it and the reason why is because um it
looks like if I'm correct I believe
we're gonna reach episode 300 before the
first of the year
it's crazy we've done 300 episodes of
the Tony Michaels podcast and the reason
why is because of you the audience you
keep coming every single day the
audience keeps building yesterday was a
huge day
I think I think the moderator said we
had over 2 000 people just on YouTube in
the live chat it's not including
Facebook twitch or Twitter
so we had a lot of folks out there
listening yesterday when Texas ball was
here
on Tuesday
so we're growing and it's because of you
it's because you're spreading the word
around you're getting you're sharing
this
experience with a lot of people and I'm
super excited to have you here the best
audience in the world
and I hope you have a great holiday I
hope today is great
I hope tomorrow is great for you
it's going to be for us hey I need I
need I I had a great break over
Thanksgiving and it was nice to take a
break so I'm looking forward to this
break so I appreciate you again hanging
tight with us through the break and uh
you know we'll be back
loud proud and not giving a [ __ ]
but make sure to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast if you're here on
YouTube right now don't forget
super important that way you get your
notifications when we come back on
Tuesday set your reminder there's that
little bell thing I guess down there I
don't know I'm not that great at this
YouTube stuff but also if you'll do us a
favor a great holiday gift for us is Go
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify Google and leave us a great
review why you're subscribing on
your favorite director you can also
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels we broadcast from the Midas
touch Facebook page but we also
broadcast from my page at the Tony
Michaels so follow us there as well and
don't forget to go over to elon's
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod that's
where the bonehead of the week poll will
be tomorrow we will put out a poll
you'll get to vote
we don't want to take democracy away
from you
um but we won't have the bone end of the
week video or the show because we'll be
off on Friday but bonehead of the week
will be coming back strong next week on
Friday don't worry don't worry we're not
going to snap doing bonehead
and if you will go visit
store.btonymichaels.com that's store and
not be tonymichaels.com
check out all the merch there and some
people have been asking about the um the
[ __ ] pants and I know the moderators
put it in the um the chant there but you
can go to
thetonymichaels.com the Tony
michaels.com the link to the hat store
is there the [ __ ] hats are there
they're in a different store because
they're a special hat and there's
several different kinds in there too if
you want the [ __ ] them hats several
people have ordered them over the last
few days so I want to make sure to point
that out to everybody where you go to
get your vacuum hats
well here's where you go to get your
commentary the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
so what do you want to do for the
Christmas show tomorrow you want to
listen to some Christmas music
maybe I'll see if the Apes and chisels
I don't know
what do you think
leave enough to you in the comments
that's what the moderators know
some great Christmas ideas if you'd like
to do at the show tomorrow I'm sure
they'll they'll let me know that's
that's what I also want you to do I want
you to go and give all the love to all
of our moderators
here on the Tony Michaels podcast or the
best moderators in the world they really
you're the best audience and they're the
best moderators I think it has something
to do with each other I really do I
think that's a thing that you know
you guys are the best audience which
makes them the best moderate they're the
best monitors make you bet I don't know
chicken or the egg type thing but we do
have the best moderators in the world so
give them some love in the chat tell
them happy holidays they have they have
kicked ass all year long
and they deserve this break too that
we're gonna get this four day break
for the holiday
they have earned it well
so I want you to give love to the
moderators in the chat
and see if if you've got ideas for the
Christmas show tomorrow and maybe maybe
put them there maybe they'll
they'll pass along the best ones or
something I don't know
oh boy
oh boy it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas I don't know are you excited
about Christmas
you know it's nice it's nice to um wake
up in the morning be with your family
and that sort of thing open some
presents maybe you know I'm not a big
surprise person though I have to be
quite honest I don't like surprises
it's maybe why I'm not that great of a
Gift Giver is because I'm not a great
gift receiver because I don't like
surprises I'd much rather you just like
hand me the thing you're gonna give me
without it being wrapped like here you
go got you a gift oh thanks
I don't like and I'm just not into
surprises at all I don't want to be
surprised I want to know
right and that's maybe maybe that's
where it comes from with the show like
ah
let's know what the hell is going on
let's not be surprised by this later on
let's know what the hell's going on
maybe that's the whole cathartic part of
it is that I absolutely do not like
surprises so I'm going to show you the
[ __ ] that you're not going to be
surprised about later on because I've
done told you that [ __ ]
which is some of the stuff we're gonna
do today I'm sure we'll get to the
shitless Roundup here uh let's see it's
Gabe Sanchez he hasn't messaged me back
I don't know if he's ready or not
probably be on in a few minutes let's do
this let's let's let's let's not wait on
Gabe Sanchez too long let's just go
straight to the shitless Roundup where
we ran up all the Tweety tweets and
trendy trends of the day start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
all the Tweety Tweets in the journey
trends of the day the [ __ ] let's round
up
oh boy I got a good one for you to begin
with you know this tax return stuff
they're gonna try to sucks the suck the
oxygen out of the room with this tax
return stuff listen don't get too
[ __ ] distracted by this
this is just another [ __ ] distraction
the Wright's going to try to use it as a
distraction and the reason why is
because literally the IRS
was not doing what they were supposed to
do which is audit the president of the
United States
it's actually a [ __ ] thing they're
supposed to do every time every year
that there's a president which we've had
a president every year for a long time
so they're supposed to do that they did
not do that and the reason why is
because Trump put someone acting in that
wasn't confirmed as is Lackey to make
sure that that didn't happen
and if you think that doesn't have to do
with the other stuff that's going on
you're out of your mind it absolutely
has to do with like the Trump trading
cards and we should mock it listen mock
it
it is super important that you mock him
over this and the thing that pisses him
off the most is that he's not a
billionaire and he's not rich he's
[ __ ] broke mock the [ __ ] out of him
to his supporters directly
you don't think that [ __ ] that
narrative and that fodder will work its
way up to his mind absolutely get in his
mind live there rent free and how you do
that on this tax thing is not about
crime it's about how broke he is that's
how you do it
um but we have to pay attention to this
January 6th of
um and the reason why is because Jack
Smith is on the case
um here is um officer Mike fanone you
know he was attacked on January 6 by
Donald Trump supporters trying to
overthrow our government and he was
trying to protect our constitution he
was trying to protect the cash but
always trying to protect Congress he was
trying to protect our democracy and this
[ __ ] has no [ __ ] to give that's
why I want to play this video he has no
[ __ ] to give for this stuff not not
even one [ __ ]
he he probably gives less [ __ ] than I
give which is incredible I can't even
tell you how hard it would be
to give less [ __ ] than me
but this guy he's there
and he's there about Donald Trump
and he's sick and tired of the Pomp and
Circumstance
and he's spot on in this video when he's
talking to reporters
and the other thing I like about officer
Fanon is he he's that
he's not
he's not media prepped right
the guy the guy isn't like you know
trying to [ __ ] impress the media or
trying to get a big interview he
wants someone to pay for what happened
on January 6 and every single [ __ ]
one of them he wants them to pay not
just the [ __ ] ones that were beating
him
trying to kill him
not just the ones that were violently
trying to go into the Capitol and hang
Mike Pence
not just the ones that were in the house
chamber in the Senate chamber trying to
steal our democracy he wants the
[ __ ] that planned it to be held
accountable too
and I know you do too and it sounds like
he's confident that that is happening
just I cannot I can understand how he
thinks it's not happening fast enough
because he was the one that was damn
near killed that day as his colleagues
were being killed and beaten so let's
listen to what fennon has to say
um
you know this isn't over and uh I'm
gonna be here until their accountability
for January 6th not political
accountability criminal accountability
Donald Trump needs to be in prison
uh his
allies who uh orchestrated and
participated in this shoe need to be in
prison and that includes members of
Congress and those who continue to Aid
and Abed this uh effort by defying
subpoenas obstructing justice and
refusing to participate in a legitimate
investigation into the activities of
January 6th those members are defying
their uh constitutional oath every
single day and I look forward to seeing
them brought to Justice that's it
uh there you have it officer vanone I
know it's hard to hear it was from a
cell phone so it's hard to hear the
audio but he's basically saying hey
Donald Trump and his supporters and his
allies that tried to commit a coup a
violent coup
need to [ __ ] be held accountable and
he's going to be there every day until
it happens and I don't doubt him and I
think I think it's a great service that
Fanon and he's a hero for our country
he was standing there every single
officer that stood there
to fight these [ __ ] buffoons these
nincompoop Nazis this shark army that is
Trump supporters that tried to steal
away our government
they're Heroes
but it goes well above and beyond that
the guy is still there fighting for Law
and Order
against the buffoons and act like every
[ __ ] day that they care about Law and
Order which they don't
just watch what the ways and committee
doesn't do
after they take power the Republicans in
the house after January they're just
watch just watch what they don't do
just watch what these committees don't
do
that's going to be the most significant
[ __ ] thing that we can draw a wedge
with
is what they don't do
I know Gabe Sanchez agrees with me even
though he probably doesn't know what the
hell I'm talking about at this point but
I know you agree with me right yeah 100
yep great great so
um uh we need you to um give us your
bank account number then and um we will
uh do you need my social my street I was
born on my mother's made a name my first
pet my school mascot yeah Street teacher
oh you need all we need all the
questions oh okay okay just in case we
need to you know hack into some emails
or something yeah so uh did you watch
the video of Fanon basically saying
Trump needs to go to prison I just
showed that video no no I didn't watch
the video okay well well um maybe you
can watch it later but yeah you can only
imagine how many because I was saying
that fanone almost gives less [ __ ] than
I do which is really I mean and yeah I
think Gabe knows me kind of person I
know the audience knows me Gage knows me
yeah I really truly give no [ __ ] I
almost I mean here I don't I don't uh
put it past him yeah considering all of
the [ __ ]
that they've had to deal with from
Republicans and and just a bunch of
people who are trying to Gaslight them I
wouldn't be surprised too like I would
hit a Breaking Point like [ __ ] it I
don't [ __ ] care well you know he's
calling out members of Congress in this
video uh which I think is probably the
most significant thing like it's easy to
say about January 6th especially if you
were one of the dudes getting their
asses kicked by his [ __ ] supporters
that he incited to come down and kick
your ass at the Capitol when you're
trying to protect democracy right right
or none of that you're trying to protect
the people that are now saying oh no no
it's not a great deal stop complaint
right well you're trying to you were
protecting the members who possibly
helped plan the [ __ ] coup the violent
Insurrection it's crazy it's kind of a
weird situation here but
um Fanon it's easy for him to say Donald
Trump needs to go to prison right they
need to jail him but it's another thing
to say that members of Congress need to
go to [ __ ] prison too yeah um but I
believe that and we're going to get this
report some time today I don't know if
it's dropped yet I don't know what time
it's supposed to drop as tax returns
became public yesterday after the Ways
and Means Committee I mean look I know
that everyone wants a conviction before
you know for Christmas under the tree
but some of this stuff is pretty good in
replacement like you've got a report
coming out you've got a and here's the
thing you've got a report on January 6
which has more details because I know
even
um even other members were saying like
there's stuff that we couldn't even talk
about because of time that's in the
report there are other people that we
believe should be pursued by the doj
well [ __ ] we didn't see any video about
of Hope Hicks testimony until this last
hearing and it was only Snippets of it
right exactly so I'm I don't there's no
telling what's in those transcripts of
Hope X alone and the other thing too is
uh in addition last night like you
mentioned we got the well at least the
report on the tax returns right their
tax returns are coming out publicly
they'll come out I think in the next I
think week or so yeah I believe well
which means that's going to be a [ __ ]
feel day because then you have all of
the people who are actually can do their
forensic accounting and they can go
through and be like this is weird this
doesn't I mean not to say that the
report doesn't already do that
but you read through part of the report
yeah yeah I read to about half the
report right now I still need to go
through because I'm debating if there
should be like a what was that for that
like a long time what was that uh
because I feel like I could based on his
history
um well I mean I mean if you just go off
as statements alone since they voted on
that yesterday yeah he's he's [ __ ]
out of his mind he's out of his and I
said I tweeted just off one of his
statements because it's all the same
[ __ ] right it's the same [ __ ]
statement he's just writing it in a
different order with a little different
wording it's same [ __ ] different diaper
I mean really that's what this is and
this is gonna be our lives for the next
18 months it really is truly going to be
that and and I was telling the audience
before you came on in the first 30
minutes that we have to even if he isn't
actually the nominee which I right
actually believe that he will be we have
to pretend it that way because we cannot
let down this [ __ ] could likely
could be indicted on several federal
charges being investigated on more
federal charges based on his tax returns
and his business dealings in New York
uh some of the January 6 maybe the
document stuff hell there could be a
whole slew of things that he's indicted
on here right and and we need to we need
to in this country just realize that the
Republican party like that about him
they [ __ ] love that about him even
though most of them called him out and
said he's a terrible businessman he's
going to ruin the country doesn't have
economic reform policy well well that
was that was when they were running
against right that was when they're
running and now they're like he's a
great businessman he's so that's this
[ __ ] he'll fix the country if he just
runs it like one of his businesses and
we're gonna find out how he ran his
business which was into the ground
because isn't this report doesn't it say
something like 105 million dollars or
something yeah so in the first uh like
it was like third or fourth pages I was
scanning through it says basically he
had he had a carryover of a net
operating loss of 105 million and so on
and so forth wait wait tell the audience
what a net operating loss is it seems
like a billionaire
she's like a billionaire wouldn't be
running on a net operating loss gave
Sanchez Yeah so basically I mean unless
you're Elon Musk and Twitter yeah yeah I
mean like for income tax purposes anyone
who doesn't know in that power brain
loss is a result of when your company or
your entity who is Trump himself
uh there's no money yeah a taxable
income within that tax period so
basically Trump is saying he uh
he won he was saying he didn't make any
money but also was saying that he had
negative he was 105 million dollars in
the hole is what he's basically saying
in 2015 he said this year he was running
for president yeah this year he
announced and he was like oh those
racists and those Mexicans come across
I'm rich I'm rich elect me I'm rich I'll
make you rich there'll be nothing but
winning there's a clip out there and I
have to find it because I think I'm
gonna use it for what was that but
there's a clip out there where he's on a
I think he's on like the view or another
talk show and he's with Ivanka and
Ivanka says something to the tune of
when I was with my dad and we were in
we're in New York he said you see that
homeless man over there right on the
street and Ivanka said yeah I do and and
Trump says that man is richer than me
yep
and obviously everyone was like oh he's
always broke he's broke his broke and we
never had the actual financials we had
some years in like the 90s but this
report again once we get to actually see
the the returns themselves
people are going to go through and say
oh yeah this guy's a [ __ ] fraud a
scam the election just like The
Apprentice pulled him out of his actual
debt that the presidency also did the
same thing there's a ton of shady stuff
that are in this report that pertain to
the actual Trump Returns the Trump
children getting these favorable loans
these things to avoid gifts there's all
all of this well and then and the
non-audit which is a thing that happens
every year it's like they're they're
talking to their you know I know that
everyone on Twitter from the right
including Elon Musk is like all the
Twitter files the real Twitter files the
real [ __ ] Twitter files is the tax
returns that Trump said to his own
because again all of this stuff happened
under the Trump Administration but this
one specifically was saying oh uh the
IRS not gonna look into this the other
crazy thing
is they go they go into detail about
these pass-throughs right and a
pass-through is basically like it's like
500 of them right yeah so a pass-through
is like that but that's a typical thing
in a bit in business is they they use
tasks yeah yeah you'll go over every
business person
every business person likely will use
yeah any means necessary to protect
themselves from tax liability or legal
liability for that matter right I mean
this is It's a capitalist Society right
it's it's but it's also it's also great
this is great fuel because if we go back
to the conversation we have with Rachel
earlier this week which feels like a
lifetime ago now with all the stuff
that's come out right but if we go back
to the conversation we have with Rachel
we have to who you mean on Monday that
was two days ago was it two days ago
that was Monday that was supposed it
feels crazy like an eternity uh was it
Monday or was it Friday I don't know no
it was during the hearing on Monday oh
that's right yeah yeah she was on with
David Bender right right and really yeah
what we had previously talked about last
week definitely feels like so long ago
okay well here's here's here's what I
want to say that that if you're if you
because Gabe's about to say what she was
gonna say if you want to listen to it
just subscribe here to the YouTube
channel all that coverage the the
pre-coverage the hearing and the post
coverage is on our YouTube channel and
the post coverage is where Rachel and
David were speaking and um Rachel
um Dr Rachel bittickoffers so that's
episode
[Music]
293. so it's episode 293. I made the
post coverage the episode that they said
but but what were you going to refer to
what she was saying so the key thing and
we've talked you know we've we've talked
about this like strategic outrage and we
talked about humiliating
right you want to make fun of them you
want to make them you want to mock them
and make them look like fools but not
not necessarily want to make the people
supporting them look like fools but you
want to make the people look like fools
that are running like Donald Trump or
Republicans so that the people that are
that potentially were once supporting
stop and go oh wait what am I doing why
would I support this
so that's the goal here
and the idea that again Trump just puts
it on a [ __ ] silver platter for us
and says I fought this long for six
years or say four years for it for four
to six years I think is how long they
they fought to get these yeah the ways a
Means Committee wanted those returns
pretty soon in his administration
because they wanted to know why the IRS
wasn't auditing why they weren't seeing
so they got their six years worth of tax
returns that are now going to be public
in the actual return format which is
great obviously certain private stuff
redacted but the actual financials are
going to be revealed to know exactly
what people are talking about and what a
beautiful beautiful thing to have for a
guy that is clearly broke desperate to
run a trading card grift right desperate
to make any money that he can possibly
well how many of the emails have we read
here online where he's like hey Gabe
I'll I'll ten times or whatever the hell
they say yeah I'll twelve hundred
percent 10x 13x one hour left okay I'm
just kidding one more hour left okay you
know what I'll give you one more hour
just to give me a dollar and then
tomorrow I'm gonna give you another it's
like I got one the other day that said
I'm officially writing forty seven
dollar a forty seven dollar check to the
campaign I clicked on the link to see
exactly what it was talking about he
said this in the email he said this in a
text and he was like I'm right he was
gonna have 47 yeah he said I'm here I'll
even I'll even oh my God it said
something to the tune of I am writing my
47 check
47 check to our movement and I'm calling
for you to match my gift oh my God 10
minutes donate here so I went to the I
went to the site right I went to the URL
because I was curious like what is
what's the fact what's behind this thing
right it's a gold check that says 47
like Trump campaign signed by Donald
Trump gold yeah and it was like okay
first off there was no [ __ ] way he
has forty seven dollars to his name to
write on this expense you can't even pay
the tax returns that we're what we're
looking that are coming out this guy has
no money to his name and this whole
thing and that's the thing that I really
hope that people take from this
especially his Trump supporters if there
was maybe ever a [ __ ] point of like
conversion
it's showing them Point Blank and saying
look this guy was broke he wasn't
successful this is the guy that you
believed was a great businessman every
business went bankrupt he did this he
did that just because he avoided his
taxes doesn't make him a great
businessman like he claimed in the
debates but everything that Hillary
Clinton has said has come true now if
you look at these returns you will also
see that you played a direct part in
making sure that this [ __ ] idiot
didn't go flat broke and he continues to
grift off you and you continue to give
him money maybe you should stop and kind
of reassess it won't convert everyone
but it might get some people if the
Democrats play it right they might be
able to get
some people converted over to be like oh
[ __ ] why am I giving money to this guy
who was a complete fraud because that
that is the message Trump is a fraud he
is broke he doesn't have any money and
he's using your hard-earned money your
American hard-earned money
to pay off his debts do you know how we
do that you want to get that narrative
and that messaging there
it to his supporters because you got to
remember they are they're not watching
this I mean there are some but they're
not watching this show they're not
paying attention to to to reality right
they're going to True social and reading
his [ __ ] post and seeing what the
King Jesus says what does our Republican
Mussolini orange Jesus say so here's
what you got to do we have to get inside
the mind of that little twit and make
sure that he absolutely keeps [ __ ]
posting about how broke he isn't and try
he keeps trying to justify how broke he
isn't and we just need to keep standing
around waving our arms and yelling and
screaming [ __ ] broke
[ __ ] broke [ __ ] broke
and and and by the time we get to next
summer because he will be the nominee
but there needs to be a challenger and
the reason why we need we as
pro-democracy people need him to have a
Challenger it showed that we can draw
more wedges and drive that [ __ ] wedge
even deeper like Rachel was talking
about by mocking them yeah you know just
making utter fools of them and making it
to where it's hard for people to support
them because they're such a joke right
and that's the whole point but we have
to have him have a foil so that we can
play him off of each other what would be
better what would be better Gabe Sanchez
than Ronda zantas standing in an
official
um some kind of press conference as
governor of Florida the state which
Donald Trump lives in talking about how
broke that [ __ ] is oh my God I
can't wait I now I I don't know if Ron
DeSantis gets in I I actually think it
would be against his interests I don't
know if he will or not but something
really deep down inside me wants around
DeSantis to run for president United
States just to see Ron DeSantis stand
there and we get to talk about it I want
the clip to play here on the show of Ron
DeSantis absolutely [ __ ] talking trying
to burn down Donald Trump's house
because he's a broke [ __ ] and he
ain't got no money
if there is any way because again that
party is so divided and so fractured
right now you look after the midterms
everyone is still pointing fingers they
you know yeah Jesse Waters blaming women
you had [ __ ] other people
blame women for everything though which
like yeah everything though which by the
way Jesse Waters blaming women when when
he like Jesse Waters blamed Jesse Waters
blamed women for not marrying men to to
win over the the vote for Republicans
keep in mind Jesse Waters is a man who
had an affair with a person that was on
his staff at Fox News
got divorced and then married that
younger woman however old she was but of
all people if you're going to talk about
the [ __ ] the sanctity of marriage
you're going to talk about as a
Christian person of course that's the
fancy Waters self-proclaims himself as a
Christian yeah he says that oh my God I
guess I don't watch that [ __ ] enough
yeah I can't even imagine Jesse Waters
running around be like yeah I love the
Bible I mean it's gross when Trump does
it but Jesse Waters really come on but
they but but again you know they
they cannot
um accept the defeat that they had so
they all have continued to point fingers
at each other and blame other people and
blame reasons you know just like [ __ ]
Elon Musk blames the FED for him losing
600 billion dollars or whatever it is in
value of Tesla like everyone can't
accept the fact that they are the actual
person who is causing their own
destruction they decided to enter the
Limelight they decided to allow people
to look into their personal lives and
their financial lives and all those
things they're the ones who brought this
on themselves they cannot play victim
especially when those people are doing
pretty shady shitty stuff you know well
to come full circle here with Jesse
Waters Elon Musk and Donald Trump all
wrapped up in one little post on on
fraud social it's this is the one that I
grabbed
uh I I saw him posted immediately I'm
like Jesus Christ who hasn't really
posted anything since then because after
those returns came out it's all been
about
uh the Caravan and uh Congress needs to
secure the border and then also look
brown people I'll distract them with
that's literally what he's doing it's
really what he's doing so here this this
is the one that I pulled and I said same
[ __ ] different diaper like literally
this is the same nonsense just in a
different order and he quotes Jesse
Waters here which is hilarious that that
anyone would go yeah Jesse Waters well
you quoted him so it must be gold oh
[ __ ] so here's the quote from Jesse
Waters which I don't even know if is a
real quote from Jesse Waters or not
um the quote is the FBI and Twitter
colluded because he
I don't know if Jess did Jesse yell it
the FBI on Twitter this was I just want
to point out this was not planned I
brought up Jesse Waters unrelated to
this post this is not we did not listen
I'm telling you here at the show when
you see my Twitter feed because some
people are like why does he retweet so
much I'm like dude I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna
show you that [ __ ] on the show that's
why I'm tweeting so I can find it so I
can find that [ __ ] I want to be able to
find it easy so I just retweet it
um so uh the quote from Jesse Waters is
the FBI and Twitter colluded to elect
Joe Biden
um which is hilarious because the FBI
was doing what the FBI does they do law
enforcement and they were trying to make
sure they were enforcing a law that it
seemed like an order right maybe maybe
that Twitter users were breaking so they
wanted to make sure that that you know
the Twitter uh was cooperating with them
and making sure that they enforced the
law I guess you know who knows
um seems like you know pretty easy stuff
but to to right Wingers it's definitely
rocket science or rocket surgery
depending on how you look at it yeah um
the grandpa Poopypants goes on to say
after he quotes Jesse Waters here he
says in other words the 2020
presidential election was rigged and
stolen and began blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah what should be done about
such horrible thing you should let me
know elected and cheating
and destroy the country question mark
same [ __ ] it's it's the same [ __ ] we've
been reading and that's literally why I
pulled it because normally I pull them
because I'm like oh this might be
significant news but the significant
news to me in this statement was it's
the exact same nonsense you want to know
what the significant news to me in the
statement was yeah what is it him
spelling rig with two G's that is try GG
well you know he's probably going to be
he's probably going pretty fast really
he may have to wipe at that point you
know and it's kind of crusted up on the
old ass cheeks so he's trying to hurry
up so he can get you know yeah it's it's
it is always the same it is always and
also the connection the other funny
connection between Donald Trump and
Jesse Waters is that Donald Trump wrote
a review of Jesse Waters book as like
former president Donald Trump number 45
has to say this only to find out that
the review that was written by Donald
Trump was pulled from the publisher wait
a second you're saying that Donald Trump
wrote it and then the bubbler's like no
we don't want to put it in no no no no
no uh uh way around that there was
already a there was already a review and
quote that I believe was from the
publisher
and he just stole it and then Trump took
it and then copy pasted
Jesse Waters book even better so you
think Melania helped him with that she
tends to do that 100 she was like when
they go low we also go low because we
gotta copy what they say exactly and say
it as if it's our own and then of course
when they get busted they're like I
didn't I didn't write that speech I
didn't make that thing right I didn't I
didn't I didn't fire those people right
well I didn't say those things in front
of a microphone and a camera that you're
saying I stole yeah you did well I
didn't say there are airplanes during
the Revolutionary War it was the
teleprompter
there were airplanes weren't there
Revolutionary War what year was that
1901. okay so
here's the thing is you're telling me
that Jesse Waters wrote a book I don't
believe that I mean he may have a book
with his name on it do you think he
actually wrote the book I don't know I
don't know it's one of those things like
a lot of these people I bet a woman
wrote it for him what do you think
probably I mean a lot of these people
are married an unmarried woman I've been
an
route that brought
there is probably someone that they
hired online it's got to be poetic right
there's got to be you know yeah there's
some there's some irony I am sure to
that book because a lot of these people
what I imagine what I know from some
Publishers you'll have a ghost writer
you might write like an outline and say
this is what I want they'll interview
you for additional details but they've
got someone else who ghost writes it for
you and of course a ghost writer is
never labeled on the book they don't get
credit they get paid for writing the
book but then the person who is about or
wrote it slaps their name on it or they
have a co-author like like Bill O'Reilly
has done this a lot in his career like
he's oh he's got so many great books
like Bill O'Reilly's yeah it's a [ __ ]
brilliant person like it's all the
assassination ones right right
assassination of and he didn't write any
of that [ __ ] he didn't write any of that
[ __ ] he all's he did was someone else
wrote it he read it he put He put the
the few words that he wanted into it and
they Incorporated in there and that's it
because you're like exactly I co-wrote
right I I changed the order of that
sentence and you got to remember too the
other side too is like the person's like
look I don't have to do Bill O'Reilly in
this case it's like I don't have to do
much work because my name is what's
going to sell this book so I can throw
in a period here and there I don't
begrudge that no no I don't regretch
that but you know this whole phony thing
where you're acting like you wrote the
book at the [ __ ] yeah just say you you
officially endorsed it that's why you
wanted but your name and you're picked
out on the front that's all I'm saying
um let's see so there's is there
something going on are they are they
voting on something right now oh I don't
know
um I'm trying to see and Cal Rittenhouse
is trending right now too Mike please
so I shared well I don't he might be
sharing from that thing the last night
he went to a The Right Stuff dating app
like oh yeah the picture [ __ ]
yeah it's funny because anytime I go
into the whenever he posts something
because here's the thing Kyle were in
house outside of being a murderer uh
reminds me is this [ __ ] yeah yeah of a
few things one he is now trying to take
this Marco Rubio approach where he's
always throwing in like a Bible quote or
verse or something where he tweets Bible
verses yeah all the time he's trying to
if you know if you go back if you go
back to the end of last like the middle
of last month I want to say he started
posting quotes from or like verses from
the Bible not only that but he would
start to ask questions like oh what's
your favorite thing blank or blank you
know that like oh I'm not just a
murderer I'm also one who can take
questions from an online like you know
BuzzFeed article and so this is another
thing so he's not only trying to like
Rebrand himself but he goes in uh and
posts this thing about piece of advice
for the piece of advice for the day dump
your liberal boyfriend
or girlfriend
and that's great that's a great that's a
great joke by the way yeah I mean it's
funny it's hilarious I commented and
whenever I comment on these things I
always get a bunch of people like you
would proved to be innocent I'm like all
right cool down calm down I love Elon
too yeah
so yesterday I think I wrote uh
I said oh the right stuff now has
murderers on it yeah checks out well you
know what's funny is is I guess is this
his girlfriend
I'm assuming I'm assuming so because if
you go to her profile if she if there's
a lot of pictures of them together right
but if you go to her if you go to her
profile he's in the here he's in the
header image he's in the banner ow
really so so maybe not girlfriend but
definitely stage five cleaner man I
don't know someone's painting someone
you remember wedding wedding crash right
stage five Clinger yeah dude stage five
I don't know I mean I think he I want to
say that he's a stage five cleaner oh
okay that might be the case here well
either way if you look at the back of
her um
her little hoodie there it says dump
your liberal boyfriend
which here's the thing if these two are
dating why would they be promoting a
dating app if they're dating each other
right
I that doesn't make much sense to me the
other the other funny thing too is like
dating apps you know they serve the
purpose you can meet up with people you
can hook up depending on what you're
looking for right but dating OPS dating
apps Also Serve uh under the assumption
that you use it you meet someone and
then you never have to go back to that
thing to use again because you found a
relationship well it depends I mean
maybe you're just looking for sex no no
that's what I'm saying like you could go
through and be like Oh I'm not looking
for anything serious I just want to like
meet people hook up hang out whatever
but if the end goal is like you want to
meet the right person right you want to
[ __ ] meet the right Christian
conservative [ __ ] cuck who will carry
around and how dating sites became a
thing right that you would find the
person you want to marry right and then
everyone and then humans are like well
we just want to [ __ ] so then they just
sites work what I mean is dating sites
work within a a demographic that says
the end goal right ideally is for one
person to meet another person right and
start a relationship and then say okay
oh I don't need this app anymore oh okay
so here we go see here's the here's the
thing I I got married before dating apps
even easier yeah yeah I've never used a
dating app I don't know what the [ __ ]
dating app is I mean to me it's just
let's [ __ ] kind of thing like you know I
don't even know how where you are in
like I would say it's depending on where
you are in your age but also where are
you wait a second what are you saying
about me
it's also something where it's like it
depends on like where you are kind of in
your yeah right relationship status as a
person to be like that's what that's
what I'm confused about if they're
together yes are they on a dating app
as why they're there because if you're
dating you're like well I met now the
real question is did they meet through
the right stuff dating app
now if they met in per if they met in
person then then being at this event
it's [ __ ] dumb if they met in the app
I could see some reason why they would
be there but also again if they met
someone on the app that means that
you're the right stuff in data which by
the way the right stuff is full of bunch
of dudes and no females we already know
this because and a bunch of dudes that
love this guy because he murdered
exactly right they're [ __ ] oh my God
I'm only here to look at photos of Kyle
writtenhouse do you think he's do you
think he has a profile on right stuff
I wouldn't know because we don't know
his profile
I mean it's probably like uh future mass
murderer um
oh [ __ ] Gotta Wait gotta got away with
it 69. yeah yeah something like that
that may be his handle but I don't know
if uh oh [ __ ] but if I I who knows holy
[ __ ] who who knows who knows what his
profile is but I'm sure I'm sure that if
he was on the app uh he was my uh he was
one of uh thousands a few thousand other
men on the app because that's probably
what the user base is right well the
right stuff is where you go if you want
to meet a dude and he also does [ __ ]
like this where it's like God my god
dude this is [ __ ] owning yourself
almost two weeks ago he said this and
it's still going around of course and
it's you know underneath this name when
it's trending they pull this up right I
mean he's had other ones too the other
day where he complained about
um
he was like my life will no longer be
normal it'll never be the same after
what happened to which I responded I
said yeah you probably could have
avoided this whole thing if you never
showed up to this right to kill people
with the gun
in the first place and then people were
like oh he was asked to be there he's
like no that was a debunked in court no
one asked him to be there he just showed
up but again if he never illegally
purchased this gun through a friend in
the state of Wisconsin because he wasn't
old enough and he's from Illinois and
people like oh we crossed 20 minutes
over the Border doesn't matter they
still cross state lines right he still
illegally obtained a firearm because he
had a friend buy it his mommy had to
drop him off and his mom dropped him off
and he still underage used a firearm
that he didn't own and decided to walk
the streets now at the end of the day he
still murdered two people and the thing
that I find so crazy we feel like oh is
a pedophile is this person is like look
I'm not defending these people's history
right he's just terrible things but the
idea this is the thing that they that
Kyle Rittenhouse and everyone else on
the right
cannot understand
there's a thing called double jeopardy
okay uh but when people go in and they
say
this guy killed people who deserved it
okay but you know that they're bad
because they have a criminal record and
they went to jail so they already served
their time right again not defending
these people they did bad stuff but they
served their time and he killed them
but but all these people are under the
assumption
that Kyle writtenhouse knew they were
bad people
so it Justified him killing them like it
doesn't make any sense so whenever you
hear them defend that stuff you're like
well how would he would have known he
didn't know because he didn't live there
he never he's never met these people so
the idea that he would have gone out
with the gun with the idea that he was
going to kill people sounds way worse
than what you think it sounds like and
all these people are [ __ ] idiots well
everything they say is way worse than
what they think it sounds like like this
idiot speaking of Double Jeopardy
because this was another one of the
grandpa poopy pants the statements the
other day the Cheetos Cuban on her had
to post something I think he's done this
four or five times with this double
jeopardy [ __ ] as if he thinks he thinks
the impeachment
is the same as a criminal indictment he
thinks they're the same apparently but
she does not understand that that but
that they're different but he's I hope
he does I hope he does I hope he [ __ ]
freaks out more because we talked about
this the other day we talked about this
the other day about how we want their
confusion of of a referral and a
conviction and things like that only
better the cause because right it makes
that party fractured even more and this
guy go [ __ ] insane and admit to stuff
right out in the open well the other
thing too is you noticed that when they
referred him criminally there was no
Civil War did you notice that I didn't
know if anyone else there was no Civil
War that happened because they referred
him for criminal verse but here's here's
what he said this is yesterday at some
point yeah uh in his rage again same
[ __ ] different diaper here but here we
go he said the fake I'm not no I why the
[ __ ] did he capitalize fake here
I don't know he's got an iPhone right
am I wrong about this he's got an iPhone
yeah and an iPhone when you're typing it
out it wouldn't he would have to
actually hit the capital f
no that's not necessarily true if he's
written it a certain way over and over
and over again yeah let's participate
the way she wants itself like I've had
that happen to me where I'm like no [ __ ]
I only spelled it that way a couple
times well you should see what it types
out when I start typing in the POR and
then it just goes in a it's it's weird
it's weird it's weird that my keyboard
does that but here he says the fake
charges made by the highly partisan
unselect Committee of the January of
January 6 has have already been
submitted
prosecuted and tried in the form of the
impeachment hoax number two none of that
none of that is true none of that there
was no like he's getting the political
the political trial that happened in the
Senate
confused with a Criminal prosecution it
really clearly does not understand I
don't know laws yeah and who thought of
it but then he says I won
he yelled it I won convincingly he
didn't even have an exclamation point
after convincingly that's how I'm
reading it Gabe Sanchez I won
convincingly
um and then he then he goes on to say
double jeopardy anyone
which he's referring to the fact that
he's already been criminally tried for
this apparently so you can't criminally
try him again which is I I would almost
bet
that he's gonna try to use this here
he's going to try to get his attorneys
to make this argument in court when he's
criminally indicted yeah it is going to
be [ __ ] hilarious to watch a judge
just absolutely murder his attorneys if
they try to make this stupid [ __ ]
argument right because also it's you
know any it's funny because of like oh
well the trial of my impeachment is the
same thing as a criminal trial
um these other crimes the other thing
too is he's admitting that it's crime
right and and not only that but also the
fact that like right they I didn't think
they have and I've already been I've
already been prosecuted for it it's like
okay fine even if you even if you wanted
to play the game of like fine one to one
they're equal you can't be done again
there's another three [ __ ] referrals
for criminal charges that they made
against him and that's not that and that
is not even including whatever the doj
has on him because we already know that
there's going to be more in the report
and the doj's already working and you
got Jack Smith who's already get
subpoenas and he's accelerating the
process
so even if there was a one-to-one
comparison to be like oh yeah okay fine
they canceled out Double Jeopardy you
won't get charged again
uh what about the other ones the other
ones just go away we're no not at all
well and this is this I'm telling you
he's he's trying to make it to where all
the trolls Will Will just all the Maga
supporters that that will be that's
gonna be their calling card when he gets
indicted they're gonna be like never
Jeopardy oh what a man what about have
you seen the movie with Tommy Lee Jones
Double Jeopardy have you seen that movie
huh let me give you the link to the
YouTubes I'm serious they're gonna
they're gonna be saying that [ __ ] but
the other thing too is the reason that
Trump announced he was running for
president way early is because he looked
at the situation and said okay I can
lose the money here but I can make more
money on this other gift right but if I
announce early uh because he he knew he
[ __ ] knew this was coming and he said
okay well how do I uh alleviate the
situation as much as possible and push
the blame on them if I announce I'm
running for president and they are now
balance these referrals for criminal
charges and the doj comes after me I As
Trump can then say this is a political
circus you're all coming after me
because you don't want me to be
president again well first off yeah
nobody [ __ ] wants to be president
again because you're a goddamn [ __ ]
idiot but also
you're broke but also
you've ruined this country you've you've
created the worst possible image of this
country that our founding fathers
developed right they put on that [ __ ]
paper that you wanted to rip up and say
oh I'm the president forever
at the end of the day that is the reason
why he announced early he was like oh I
need a way to get out of this so I can I
can point blame and say that the reason
they're announcing they're coming after
me is because I'm a political candidate
this is a political hit job they're
coming after me how dare they I'm the
victim yeah you're the Vic you're the
reason for your own destruction you
[ __ ] idiot
he's he is an idiot that is for sure I
mean I gotta hand it to him
I am the victim I'm not the reason they
are the reason
it's just like at any point they will
they will throw someone under the bus
that's why it's like I'm very much
waiting for them to throw or him to
throw his kids under the bus
um whenever possible oh he's definitely
on these tax returns going to
um I find it funny that James Woods and
Tom Hanks are trending at the same time
something makes me think that it's not
because they're both really
famous popular good actors I don't know
I'm just saying why is James Woods
trending here I want to say no there's
oh is it oh oh Jesus Christ is it a
Twitter false thing I don't know this is
Benny Johnson is it must be yep oh that
no that's December oh this is old that's
all News why is he trending go to latest
go to latest
see the problem is is it's it's you're
going to get a lot of simps in here yeah
because they they they run to cover his
ass
James Woods is that it no no um oh hey
maybe this is is this something no
that's from September 29th but I'm sure
it's packed full of stupidity is Nick
Adams do you think Nick Adams has
anything to do with the trading guards I
think I have to cut I think that come on
he's gotta be he was someone in the
background that was like I you should
you should definitely get these trading
cards here okay like I honestly like oh
yeah [ __ ] sucky dick here Trump like
I honestly think that keep going it's
great it's just Nick Cannon he's like I
got a great idea we can do these digital
trading cards like Pokemon but it's like
[ __ ] broke him on it Pokey Don like
that that's that's not a trading card
this is a training card this is a
[ __ ] Trading Card let me go down in
another Crocodile Dundee yeah yeah
that's a great he's like this is it
that's not a knife this is a knife
um but the idea that Nick Adams Nick
Adams is
what I am and it's
let me tell you something Nick Adams is
the greatest wedge that we can drive
between these [ __ ] weirdos out there
that sent for because he is like just
the the
I don't I don't know how to describe it
but he's like the Pied Piper of these
[ __ ] these kind of crazy man I
wouldn't be surprised if you know I'm
not saying he is but I wouldn't be
surprised if alpha male Nick Adams had
some um uh
let's say a pornographic material that
wasn't uh oh definitely need to look at
Nick Adams laptop for sure look look I
don't know what age the porn is
but I would also say I don't know maybe
it's a certain maybe it's not the female
kind of uh
demographic right well that's could be
that could be we watch I don't know this
guy it just feels like every [ __ ]
tweet outside of this guy being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] guzzling Trump Humper this
guy is non-stop none
stop
simping for Trump and projecting this
alpha male testosterone and it's like
dude dude if you really were dude if you
really were you'd be at the [ __ ] gym
pounding some [ __ ] weights maybe some
dudes I don't know whatever you're
[ __ ] liking is I don't care but if
you're gonna project this
listen this guy 100 is the easiest way
to [ __ ] with any magazine or really Elon
scent for that matter because he sent
for Elon dude he thinks Elon is some
kind of masculine man or some [ __ ] but
then yeah he it I'm sure I'm sure Nick
yeah is one of the largest collectors
I'm sure Nick Adams is one of the
largest collectors of Hunter Biden dick
pics it might be so you think he stores
his 100
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure Nick Adams
was like hey I've got some ideas for
nfts and they're like all right what are
they he's like okay the first one is
gonna be Hunter Biden's dick like
honestly honest to God
foreign
they're like like I don't think that's
gonna work and they're like okay okay
well he's like okay fine we got Trump in
the in the in like the full ground but
in the background we got Hunter Biden's
dick and they're like dude calm down man
weirdo man well he um let's see he's on
Cameo I'm let's let's just look at his
profile here because there's a couple
tweets that he put out that I want to
see if they're real because literally
when if you see a fake tweet from this
guy you would not know if it's fake or
not no honestly it every day I look at
the tree and I go like I want to be like
this guy's in on the whole [ __ ] thing
like he's in he sees the game right and
he knows that he that he's not serious
but then I'm also like no he's dead
seriously dead serious look at this it
says this is art that I'm assuming he
made I don't know I don't know
he says no amount of Lies can hide his
alpha male greatness what's funny about
this is he tweeted I don't know like
last week he's like an alpha male does
not have to say it Savory does the alpha
male doesn't get oh oh it's like an
alpha male doesn't have to put Alpha in
the name like here he is here he is yeah
here he is on his cameos
a true L for male doesn't have to tell
other people that they're an alpha and
that is exactly what is due that he does
he doesn't do it he does it all the time
because it says literally Nick Adams in
parentheses L for Mike well right but
look at this his Cameo even he's even
saying no amount of Lies can hide his
Alpha so not only that but he's also
posting in the third person right it's
it's like it's great it's fantastic I
mean really honestly there could be no
security the funniest thing I saw the
other day was Nick Adams yes
was it that one was it about the straws
one the straws I don't well he was
saying let's see if I can find he tweets
so much and he treats that yeah I feel
like he's just in his house he's like
that's a good tweet well like that's all
he does oh that gave me a hard-on uh
here's more about Hunter Biden's [ __ ] he
says no no serious person this country
cares about Donald Trump's tax returns
I'd much be much more interested in
seeing Hunter Biden's
[ __ ]
he forgot he forgot conch
he forgot it
let me hear Let me I'm looking I'm
looking for this I had one oh he's such
a [ __ ] well there was one where he he
was saying he's not gonna do something
um
oh I remember his KFC and Pizza Hut was
that one [ __ ] real I seen something
and then I'm like dude he's like his own
it's crazy man
uh uh hold on let me here we go America
needs to turn back to paper ballots and
the Bible look people most ballots in
this country are paper ballots you and
the fact that they hate mail-in ballots
Gabe all male imbalance yeah all of them
a hundred percent of them are paper
ballots why the [ __ ] don't they get this
stuff it's how in the [ __ ] I just what a
[ __ ] bonehead and really honestly I
could go through and say every one of
these tweets are [ __ ] dumb but I
ain't got enough time to type all this
[ __ ] in dude it's nonstop I had a tweet
somewhere here's a great one here's a
great one here's a great one for him
straight white males are the most
depressed demographic in America today
well I don't know if he's in that
demographic but you know the other thing
too is he's I don't know if he is an
American like if he got if he's still on
a green card kind of thing I don't know
whatever I don't know I don't know
but it's it's the constant
self-owned
and here's another here's another one
here's another one we alpha males he's
referring to himself here have a certain
presence about us when we're in the
company of an alpha male when you're in
the company of now male you know it dude
you you literally said you you don't
have to say it to know it why are you
saying it well yeah it's it's clearly
the same reason why Trump's why Trump
talks about
stunning hands you know like it's it's
the reason why
here it's the reason why Trump has to
always talk about I've got big hands and
I cannot lie except you do and it's the
reason why Trump has to have digital
trading cards where it's him palming a
basketball because he has to really
emphasize the fact that he has big hands
and they're big just like Michael
Jordan's right and that is why he's
great and it's like dude this guy is is
the the overcompensation and the
projecting it's just like non-stop well
here's another one from Nick Adams with
the projecting Donald Trump lives in
Adam kinzinger's head rent-free are you
[ __ ] kidding me I mean you know I'm
not an animal kingdinger fan I mean
maybe maybe a couple days this year I
was an Adam kinzinger fan yeah but that
was it he got a couple days out of me
right you know this whole nonsense that
him and Liz Chaney are on the select
committee and somehow that made some
Heroes look folks it's the bare minimum
it's the bare minimum to make sure that
people are held accountable when they
when someone tries to commit a coup
against our democracy especially a
former president so am I impressed by
Adam kinzinger and Liz Cheney not that
[ __ ] much I mean they reached the bar
of I don't know yeah they the Democracy
in which they were elected yeah they did
the job that they were hired to do good
you know right for the same reason that
the committee wasn't partisan it was
bipartisan so when you see Trump posted
there's an idling partisan committee
it's like no it was bipartisan you had
two Republicans like two real
Republicans that were on there and like
you know like Tony said uh we don't
agree with Liz Cheney or Adam Kinsey
around what they decide
Adam's a representative of my home state
of Illinois and I don't like the fact
that he doesn't you know like he's still
on the very Central will object to
things that should be human rights of
every person in this country
but when it comes to democracy yeah he
did his job in terms of sitting on a
committee and bringing up the fact that
Trump is a guy that incited an
Insurrection and was actively trying to
overthrow the government to make sure
that he could stay in office for an
additional term even though he lost by 8
million votes God I'd love to stay on
the top of insurrection but look what
Nick Adams tweeted he tweets a lot man
he tweets oh my God this one this one
was so desperate this one was so
desperate he's definitely he's
definitely trying to get the attention
of two alpha males right it's it is okay
I'm gonna I can't find where this tweet
that tweet that I made about this but
I'm gonna go into his profile and find
it because it's it's hilarious how mad
he got
about straws and alpha males
um this one here this tweet here yes
which one sorry
no no no no no there's an additional one
where he he contradicts himself within
uh within two tweets because he says
Kirk Cousins and Trevor Lawrence are the
two drippiest quarterbacks in the league
No Cap now I just learned what no cap
means what
yeah I don't know this [ __ ] what do you
think what do you think I don't know
what no cat meant my my [ __ ] teenage
son had to tell me what the hell that
[ __ ] is oh my what the hell is no cap
he's like well it's the opposite of cap
I'm like yeah I know that dummy
and no [ __ ] is the opposite of cap No
Cap would be the opposite of cap
it's ridiculous so
um you you sound like a guy who yeah who
tells good get off my lawn right that's
the image of you right now oh I was like
well it means it means it means the
opposite of cap and you're like yeah but
what does cap mean right yeah
who's on first what's on second I don't
know who's on third
but I I was like yeah I get that but so
they explained what Captain No Cap mean
yes
so okay here's one
here is here is one tweet from Nick
Adams yeah
oh actually you had the Tweet there you
so you pulled the Tweet if you go two
down from where that one is
this one here I cannot bear one more
second right is that is that it that's
the first one that's the first one okay
here it is
that's that one and I cannot bear one
more second of drinking through drinking
my water through a paper straw
it's time to take a stand so he's so
he's complaining about a paper straw
so he's most of the time let me tell you
an alpha would just throw away the paper
straw and drink right out of the cup you
[ __ ] loser right I mean if we don't
want to drink is there like is there a
reason why he's drinking water out of a
straw like that's the thing is like I
don't like no like what do you I've I
don't normally drink water out of straw
unless like I maybe I don't know yeah
we'll see here
everyone watches me drink water right
it's the same but I'm just like saying
bottom every time why do you need is it
because your your teeth are sensitive in
the cold water makes it hurt you know
but if you click on the next link that I
sent you okay so keep in mind I cannot
bear one more second of drinking water
through a straw
you know [ __ ] complaining right
so he's he's literally saying he's
drinking through straws so he's
admitting he's admitting that he he will
no longer drink water out of a straws
because he doesn't like it right and
then
wait this is this is like just days
after uh I think it's a a day after it's
the very next day it's like less than 24
hours later he tweaks out real men don't
use straws no you gotta say in his voice
no no okay okay bring up the first one
God damn you oh
come on okay yeah see I I'm I'm I lost
it in the feed I mean
where is it oh it was after the uh those
are the drippy the no cat ribs no the
happiest these guys are the drippiest
man drip drip I know what drip means oh
I didn't know what Nokia means okay
let's see Nick Adams does not have the
drip no well obviously here's okay
here's the okay so yeah
uh I cannot bear one more second of
drinking my water through a paper straw
it's time to take a stand so does that
mean Nick that you don't want to drink
through straws so that would that would
assume that and I'm giving Nick Adams
the benefit of down here by making my
voice deeper and more like because he
does he does kind of have a I could talk
like this I could say I'm not gonna do
this in a paper straw anymore I'm not
gonna stand for this anymore
real men don't use straws
oh oh
anybody else want Gabe Sanchez to do
Nick Adams video or you just read yes
you remember when you were reading text
messages
um so when the mark Meadows text message
drops I text Gabe I said hey dude you
better get your [ __ ] fireplace and
your pipe ready yeah because I need to I
need thousands I need to get to that
because there's obviously there's a lot
of them there's a lot there's a lot of
text message but you should do you
should do maybe that should be like a
New Year's resolution thing in January
you can do or you can do a series of
videos where you're you know reading
from Nick Adams Twitter feed oh Nick
Adams
I could make a living making cameos I do
have a cameo account which I have never
activated but they were like hey make a
cameo account it's like okay oh so you
can't I can't actually go buy a cameo no
no because I never set it up but I have
it just grabbed the handle right no well
I I have the handle but they also were
like hey here's your account because
because it's an invite only kind of
thing nice oh wow
saying that I'm
uh I'm not saying that I'm uh I didn't
go eat my baby just because I saw
someone in the comments say that but I
will say I'm not worthy of that I don't
think anyone would really buy a cameo
from me but the idea that I could be
what would you do in a cameo I mean I
mean what would you imagine just be
characters what do you think that
because uh remember we had Austin Archer
on and I'm not I'm gonna tell on him
here yeah um Austin makes a lot of music
and stuff right yeah
and he's a talented artist and he makes
great tick tocks
um any India's and he post them on
Instagram and stuff too you just go
follow Austin Archer My Pal Austin
um but he was telling us and I don't
know if it was on air or not so I might
be you know telling on him here a bit
but didn't he have someone in Cameo want
they were going to pay him for like
pictures of his feet or some [ __ ]
I don't remember this maybe he said that
this was a year ago when we talked about
this what's it it wasn't it yeah because
it was Thanksgiving right because we did
the turkey the beard that you guys
didn't
um but yeah so so I think they were
requesting he's like no I'm not doing
that no I'm not it's not enough money I
wouldn't be surprised he might have
mentioned that but I I also uh do you
think people would request pictures of
your feet I don't know I don't know
I got weird feet man would you do it
would you do it for a price what's the
price well why would I do it on Cameo
why would our audience our audience
wants to know and I want to embarrass
the [ __ ] out of you so tell us 500 you
would you would send it if I know you
got to think of you got to think of the
action you're gonna get people in the
chat mods people who are willing to pay
500 bucks look man yeah I got to pay my
rent somehow you got to think of the
usage of these things if I send out a
photo I don't get paid in perpetuity
like Trump does on 10 of every sale I
only get the one sale right and then
that person gets to make as many copies
as they want and they can sell those
nfts like a [ __ ] exactly
if you sold for 500 bucks if you sold a
picture your feet that [ __ ] would end up
on Twitter oh yeah 100 yeah 100 and so
you got to draw like a smiley face on
your big toe or some [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah something like that but
when people is there anyone in the chat
right now that would actually pay 500
bucks for a picture of Gabe Sanchez's
feet
because I feel like now that I'm doing
this I deserve a commission or some [ __ ]
yeah you can you can get you can get a
little bit off the top well you know I
gotta make a living dude if you want to
license the likeness or image or name of
Gabe Sanchez's feet you know you'll be
like the nft international LLC so you've
got a cameo right I do have a cameo I
have not set it up I'm literally on like
this is here let's prove to everyone
that I have a cameo what you should do
is
the profile pic on Cameo set that [ __ ]
up and it's a picture of your foot
create your intro video hey look at you
in the thing anyway it says create your
intro video which means I would have to
make the thing that's like hey I'm Gabe
Sanchez and I'm making cameos hire me to
do a cameo oh yeah yeah yeah but I
haven't ever made it it's literally I'm
an alpha male an apple Mouse
cameos
but what I will whoa whoa whoa do you
can you do that on Cameo can you sell
you know that no no no no no no no oh
okay that's just only fans that's only
fans do you have an only fans no I don't
have no defense I mean we're I'm trying
to I'm I know I'm seriously
seriously if like I said I wouldn't I
wouldn't do a feet thing on Cameo right
I would do because most because you can
also see like the last amount of uh Gary
B is uh posting a price here whoa 1500
bucks for Gabe's Hunter Biden wow
damn garyvee
1500 bucks I could cover some of my rent
would you would you send would you send
a 1500 bucks
I mean it would just be between me and
Gary B and garyvee anywhere right here's
the thing here's the thing the way that
works I'm telling you it's consensual if
he's paying you 1500 bucks
to get a picture of your hog your Hunter
hog yeah then it's consensual right so I
mean that's I mean I'm totally fine with
that 1500 bucks but it's only between me
and Gary B oh you can't sell that NFD
you can't resell them nft garyvee no no
oh my God Jesus but but I do want to not
not to Pivot subjects oh yeah I was
gonna pivot when we were talking about
doing the voices because it was audio
related but Kailyn reminded me of
something I do want to I do want to
bring up before the end of the show yeah
just to [ __ ] on Elon Musk okay good
um oh yeah because we're getting to the
end here we're 40 minutes into the
second hour yeah we'll [ __ ] talking
about Feats and dicks and [ __ ] yeah well
you know it's it's the holiday week so
we get to take a break a little bit from
from mocking these idiots and we can
have fun and talk about dick pics and
Gabe's dick pics and Gabe's feet picks
on Cameo yeah so you can't sell a dick
pic on Cameo no nudity on Cameo so what
do you like like um if a porn star is on
Cameo and they and someone wants to pay
I mean because that's what they do
that's just like a message they can be
like hey so then you'd have to go to
their only fans I don't know how this
one you'd have to go to only only fans
is where you're like hey can I get this
like I can make a request or uh I get a
photo or a video I got you because I
think that was part of like like when I
was looking into PornHub because we're
looking at streaming on PornHub and you
gotta apply to stream on PornHub you can
apply to be a model so do I have to
submit my hunter Biden I don't know well
I'm I I haven't dove into what I have to
do to become a model right which it and
in and of itself kind of is like am I
right well if you if you think about it
you know Christmas is right here we've
got Hanukkah we've got all these
holidays New Year you know there's some
good themed photos you could take if you
needed to
what I'm saying if you need to submit as
a model right you say like oh look yeah
this is Christmas theme this is New
Year's theme ringing the new year what
do I like lay down dude you do what you
need to do to get us verified on right
now see that's what I'm saying I don't
know I don't know what I have to do I it
you got to submit to be a model which
means that I'm a porn star if they
accept me that's what I expect you then
I'm a porn star rather we need money to
be on the show or not and art is Art you
know but I would not say that Trump's
nfts are art right well it's stolen at
least some part of it what what's this
link you sent me here so this is uh
there's a it's the full the full video
that you can find on uh on my feed which
I tweet out it's a to a you it's a
YouTube link because because of course
after you watch this clip you'll
understand why this video was not
allowed to be uh it was not recorded or
allowed to be listened to after so this
looks like this looks like a Twitter
space right so this is a Twitter space
with uh Elon Musk and some other people
it also has
um
uh I'm blanking on his name uh George uh
uh hold on hold on George
why why does he go in Twitter spaces and
say this in uh uh George hotz okay who's
George hotz George George hotz or uh
geohot is his Alias online uh people
might remember him as when he was a kid
when he was a teenager
um maybe younger than that but he was
like probably 12 13. he jailed he
jailbroke the first iPhone
oh so he's famous for that yeah so he's
famous for that so it's a hand and then
yeah and so and then
um what ended up happening was he
created he basically created his own
Tesla and uh automated like automated
drive like self-driving
um right so let's get driving autonomy
then yeah yeah autonomous driving and so
basically what he did is he jailbroke
the iPhone that's how he first got on
the news since like 2007 or whenever it
first happened then not too long after
he was in the news for some other things
he did most recently he was in the news
for basically creating his own version
of Tesla
and then via tweet there was an
agreement that happened where he said I
will come to Twitter to work on this
problem that is right there right you're
trying to fix Twitter I will go on a
limb and try to and work for Twitter
since Elon has has since Elon yeah this
is absolutely since Elon took over he I
think it's a challenge for George
because he's like ah let's see what the
[ __ ] mess is over there I'll go work
on it right so he's at the company he's
running the room right now in this
Twitter space Elon is in there and this
is in response to last night Elon made a
tweet that said I will step down as CEO
as long as I find someone foolish enough
to run the company right I will continue
to run
uh systems uh or software and servers
so there's a lot of things that break up
from that tweet which is Elon saying
he's going to step away but only if
someone foolish enough because what he's
trying to imply is
the only people who can do it are him
or an idiot that says as much of an
idiot like if you're foolish either for
the reason you would buy a company with
a lot of money that you don't have or
you're foolish because you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing and someone
has to be just as foolish if not more
foolish to run the company so basically
he's like an idiot he sounds he sounds
like an idiot and this clip right here
proves that wholeheartedly
okay so let's let's listen now this is
the context this is yeah is this Elon
speaking here uh no it's George and then
it's Elon okay okay so let's listen to
George and the neon here let's listen
city of features as high as possible
yeah
uh I mean I think frankly if you want to
have a really high velocity of features
I think uh
we'll just need to do a total rewrite of
the whole thing
um
you know um wait seriously a total
rewrite that's your that's your
prediction for velocity
yeah
well when you say a total rewrite do you
mean starting with the skeleton or a
bunch of Engineers sit down with a
whiteboard and say what is Twitter
uh
revolutionary form I mean I just mean
like literally like there's this like
you could either try to amend the the
crazy stack that exists or uh rewrite it
but um when you okay I want to pause
here because I want to say there's
people in there you can see kind of the
Emojis popping up people are laugh
laughing at Elon because he clearly is
way out of his League here yeah so the
the other the other thing here too is so
there's now a new person who's talking
the new person who's talking is a guy
that's uh Ian okay uh Ian Broman browman
I forget I got I would have to look at
it down here at the bottom yeah yeah so
he's he jumps in because the question
here is Elon said he's going to take
over a new Co happens and he's going to
take over software and servers okay so
basically everything and how Twitter
runs he's going to take it over
so they're realistically and and uh uh
understandably asking the question of
like okay
what are you going to do how is the
company going to scale because there's
another video where Elon talks about the
financials which we can also play too
which shows just how [ __ ] they are but
this video is or this this part of the
Twitter space is talking about Elon
discussing how he's going to fix this
whole problem right he says Elon or he
says Twitter Elon is broken Twitter is
broken and in order to fix Twitter he's
talking about a ground up total
restructure
now George an engineer and Ian I believe
another engineer are like whoa who knows
who knows [ __ ] about this yeah they're
trying to understand exactly what he's
talking about because they're like wait
are you talking about you just starting
from scratch and wiping it all
or are you talking about fixing what we
already have and then Elon doubles down
and basically well not basically but he
says they want to start from scratch
and it reveals to them as well as
everyone else if you didn't already know
that Elon has no [ __ ] idea what he's
talking about
he's like he's not smart he's not
Entertainer he doesn't know about what
the [ __ ] he's talking about he's taking
an abstract idea of redoing all of
Twitter which not gonna I don't want to
spoil it for anyone but Twitter's
[ __ ] complex to redo everything from
a feed to profiles to permissions to DMS
to videos
every time you have to be redone and it
would not be done in a way that you're
like oh yeah we're just gonna flip the
switch and redo it right people don't do
[ __ ] yeah well because because we we've
uh you've been in Tech right and I I I
understand some of it fundamentally
right but past that I'm not I'm not what
I'm very much understanding what Elon is
proposing would take
based on how many engineers and people
are left at Twitter it would probably
take and that's assuming that all
Engineers dedicated all of their time no
one else was going to maintain the
existing product this would be the under
assumption they said okay everyone moves
over and works on Twitter 2.0 a total
rehash of Twitter 1.0 and we nobody like
Twitter run without yeah Twitter 1.0
runs with bugs and all these problems
and if you update software on your phone
maybe it'll work we'll see
under that assumption I would and again
I don't I'm not inside Twitter but I
have to imagine based on how many
Engineers are left and the resources
they have available and the money they
have available to pay Engineers for the
amount of time that they would be there
that it would probably take the better
half of a year
to do so to totally redo this like if
not maybe eight months to do it
that's what he's that that is what he is
proposing right now he's saying
I want to burn this thing or I want to
scrap this thing and build a new one in
parallel and then switch over
and say okay this is the new track run
but you still have to have a team
dedicated and a fair amount of people
need to be dedicated to maintain the
existing product because again Twitter
is [ __ ] complex Twitter is integrated
with their API into sites Services all
over like there's there's so many other
software apps Tangled everywhere right
and they write it based on the code of
Twitter like the whole the idea now I'm
gonna play the rest of this here is
there any kind of other Revelation other
than elon's a [ __ ] idiot in this uh
yeah because they go back yeah the
interaction gets it's it's a good okay
great all right let's let's listen when
you say when you say crazy stack what do
you mean like break it down
he didn't know have you seen have you
seen Georges like diagram no no no I
mean like what do you mean
do you think come on come on Who Who Are
You
what do you mean who am I I don't know
you gave me the [ __ ] mic I got
nothing well I I I'm doing the mic and
let's let's keep it let's keep it civil
in my space
I mean
yeah like what no no man you're in
charge of the servers and the
programming whatever like
a lot of things please take take it take
it take me from top to bottom what is
the stack look like right now what's so
crazy about it what so abnormal about
this stack versus every other large
scale system on the planet buddy come on
all right so first off amazing wow
you're a jackass okay okay okay okay all
right no no no I got I got no
credibility here by the I got no idea
first off first off
you know like
from speakers
oh freedom of speech Gabe okay let's
let's just understand what just happened
throughout that whole thing okay after
we already discussed the first part the
second part is Elon gets [ __ ] upset
he goes you're a jackass but here's the
thing what that guy Ian was asking is
not crazy it's not crazy at all because
the assumption is you're the CEO and
you're now cutting finances because your
company's in the [ __ ] [ __ ] because
you overpaid for a company and have 13
billion dollars in loans that you have
to repay back to the banks you have
interest that you have to pay back
now how do you make this how do you fix
Twitter how do you start making Twitter
make money right
and that's another video that they had
as well but in this video specifically
they're just talking about the technical
aspects he's like dude what's the
difference in in a stack and a stack is
basically the technologies that are
built or that a service is built on
Twitter Facebook Instagram YouTube all
these things the Technologies servers
languages uh uh firmware Hardware all
these things take up a stack right
that's what a stack is
now in this Twitter space he's just
asking because Elon brought it up Elon
brought it up he said he's going to do
it and he's going to completely have to
wipe it down start from scratch but the
question is valid what is different why
do you have to do that why can't you
just do it this other way why does it
have to be from scratch
please explain what the [ __ ] you're
talking about and he's like who are you
he's like I don't think dude you gave me
the [ __ ] mic because that's the truth
of it
yeah and they're laughing They're
laughing emojis because at the end of
the day this guy just got called out for
not knowing his [ __ ] proposing something
that is idiotic especially right now
when you have no money to back such a
change and you're struggling to keep the
finances and the lights on you're
selling [ __ ] office equipment trying
to make money this is the guy who's a
complete idiot and I think he's he's not
even paying rent right now of the
building either because yeah he's not
paying a rent which there you can avoid
paying rent on a legal aspect but I have
a friend who's in SF who actually just
spoke who's looking for commercial real
estate for his company and they were
talking about what's happening at the
Twitter building and he was like yeah
Elon
in so many words he's [ __ ] he can get
away with not paying for the rent right
now and obviously you know they can be
taken to court and they'll fight it
there it'll add time but at the end of
the day someone has to pay up the
commercial real estate market in SF is
not great right now no one is going in
buying up offices like they once were
uh there's no one really renting so a
lot of these companies are getting
desperate for their money and rightfully
so but when you've got Elon who has a
whole building dedicated to Twitter and
fired everyone to make money back
uh he's gonna not pay for as long as he
can which reminds me of someone else
like Trump
well that's true it seems like there's a
pattern here with these with these
[ __ ]
um you know here's the thing about Elon
that I want to say
again I totally
totally
miscalculated when I thought that he was
smart I totally missed I totally
you didn't type my word when I told you
I thought I thought he would be at least
smart enough to know not to buy Twitter
like he would be smart enough to not to
know not to do that but he has oh so
exceeded my expectations oh yeah
absolutely destroying Twitter absolutely
not only destroying Twitter but in the
meantime destroying Tesla
um it is like what's that right now
let's see I don't know it is um it is
likely that um oh boy what do we get
it's at 1 138 whoosh it was it started
at like 150 yesterday and it went down
all the way to 140. so if we remember
where this whole conversation started it
was like April was when the joke was
made right
so even if you go back to April April
was around
292 let's say 300 bucks but if I drag
this I'm just looking at like a simple
thing
the company is down from that point the
company is down 52 from April mid-april
to December now if I take it from the
point at which he took over now leading
up after the court case we have
September and they're like all right you
got to take over it started to drop down
so let's say from that point let's say
September 20th around the court case
that was coming out to now
55 from September 20th to December 21st
now if you take it from the point at
which he took over no it already dropped
a [ __ ] ton from there so it was like end
of October let's say October 25th
why why does this matter so much on
Twitter though the reason why it matters
right is because he used a lot of his
stock in Tesla to as the collateral to
gain the finances to buy Twitter right
like that was the whole thing in the
court cases they were they were really
trying to figure out how he was even
going to finance this thing but you know
how much money he's he's taken out of
Tesla yeah I mean how much stock he sold
you mean yeah how much uh it's like 26
it's around 26 billion dollars with a B
with a B with a B this time alone he
like at one point he took out eight he
took out four another time he took out
3.6 and he's selling it he's selling it
when it's low which is not I usually so
when you know what you think about money
is not a thing you do you don't sell and
and the other thing too is like
you could be like oh he's he's gonna
bite up on his low well he's not he's
not selling it when it's high either but
the other thing too is you know him
selling is is a direct impact into the
market which is while the rest of the
Market's you know you know fine okay it
was up yesterday
uh Tesla day day day day day after day
after day after day continues to go
negative negative negative negative
negative I mean year to date the whole
Tesla stock is down 65 percent
uh is there a clip um
Caitlyn's saying something about the a
clip here
is that the one you were talking about
earlier
yeah send me that link and we'll play it
before we go here because we're running
out of time yeah but um and so is Elon
and money and money you know this is
what I was talking about earlier while
your pool necklip up I want to mention
the Trump tax returns what they're going
to show and and this whole Elon debacle
with Twitter the Forbes list is nothing
but a bunch of garbage I would almost
bet that Elon was never the richest man
in the world to be quite honest with you
I wouldn't I mean that's all nonsense it
was all [ __ ] it has been it has been
a topic uh
for for a while now which is like the
the value of Tesla has been over
overvalued right it is way overvalued
and it's not actually worth that much
um
and so a lot of people like oh no no of
course you've got the Simpson the
[ __ ] Tesla for life people and all
that [ __ ] and they're gonna fight
fight fight to say oh he's the richest
man the smartest man well
just in the last [ __ ] two weeks he
has lost his position as the richest man
in the world and he's also beginning to
lose two companies at the same time now
when this all started before we took
over I said he was going to lose the
possibility of owning or being a
leadership position for both companies
Tesla
and Twitter
that was before I actually thought this
thing was going to really go through
but now that it really has gone through
he has no control over this [ __ ]
downward spiral and the thing is the
more bad news that comes out about Trump
is directly tied if if you guys want to
go back feel free to fact check me on
this one but if you look back at the
last four or five Twitter files and that
like announcement drops they dropped the
announcement right on the same day as a
trump bad news oh Trump 17 counts of
fraud for the Trump organization
uh January 6th Twitter files dropped
that was on Monday Tuesday or on Tuesday
or that was Monday on Tuesday yesterday
they uh were like hey we've got these
tax returns coming Twitter files drop
like it seems like the two have
something to do with it there it's not a
coincidence okay it is not a coincidence
and it's clearly lined up and every time
Trump news Falls that's bad for him
Twitter files drops and in in [ __ ]
right lockstep Tesla drops even more so
you would think that Elon would be like
hey maybe we don't don't release the
Twitter files anymore guys and and
Tesla's like ah look there goes down in
the market like that's honestly what is
tanking again well let's let's listen to
this and this apparently he's talking
about finances here is this the same
this looks like it's the same one he's
just he's just talking about the money
as opposed to how stupid he is on actual
technology let's listen because of the
nature of this transaction uh where
there's 12 and a half billion dollars is
dead and the Fed rate has been going
crazy
um there's on the order of a billion and
a half ish of Debt Service thing that's
required so we're talking about like uh
net cash outflow if you didn't make any
changes of
on the order of like six six and a half
billion next year with uh Revenue
probably tracking to
three
so
that's like a negative cash flow
situation of three billion dollars a
year not good
uh yeah no [ __ ] Sherlock says Twitter
has one billion in cash
then you go out does it so that's why I
spent the last five weeks cutting costs
like crazy
I think we also got to get the
advertisers
well yeah well I mean I mean this is the
thing is not only not only has Elon just
burned a [ __ ] ton of cashier yeah he
he's absolutely destroyed his ability to
make any of it back right he also makes
though he does make a claim he does make
a claim in that clip which I think will
be very interesting okay let's let's
listen here yeah
um but the like I said I've spoken to a
number of the advertisers they're
they're
the requests are not
uh fuzzy or or irrational or like get
off the [ __ ] they're like quite
reasonable they're like please show us
an Roi that makes sense
and I'm like yes I agree if I were in
their position I would also want an Roi
that makes sense especially when when
headed into uh difficult Economic Times
which is funny because a lot of the ants
that are running on Twitter are Tesla
ads yeah um which is funny but but but
what he's saying here is that because
you got to remember these people were
advertising with an Roi before Elon took
over okay so you could have been taken
over and would have been fine
the same
[ __ ] but let's listen
where these questions are asked a lot
more than in prosperous times in
prosperous times there is plenty of
budget for advertising
um and you can you can get away with
okay this [ __ ] [ __ ] there is more
capital and more cash inside Corporate
America right now than almost any time
in modern history if and if he had any
[ __ ] clue about any of this he would
know that that corporate profits are at
a record all-time low they're stuffing
cash into their pockets you [ __ ]
bonehead what are you talking about that
there's he's acting like companies don't
have capital for advertising this is so
stupid and he's acting like that the
unemployment rate is you know 15 and
there's no [ __ ] demand you are such
an idiot Elon you are such a [ __ ]
bonehead let's keep listening to the
Bone editory let's see how if it can get
any more bone-headed with uh unclear Roi
but when times are tough then then the
hard questions of return on investment
are asked and when you do not have a
clear answer then advertisers don't want
to advertise because they're being sane
um that's the main issue
um so
uh this is important so now with the the
changes that we're making here on uh
massively reducing the burn rate
um and uh building subscriber Revenue I
now think that Twitter will in fact be
okay next year
okay how many 28 subscribers does he
have Gabe how many uh hold on let's
let's see because if someone someone had
a GitHub repo for this uh let's see okay
I mean even if we just even if we give
him the benefit of the doubt and double
the amount that is the estimate right
and then we take that revenue is it
three billion dollars because what was
it it was it was uh what did I say it
was like even if you took a 300 000
number there four hundred thousand um
well hell give him give him three
million give him three million eight
dollar users right yeah well that's
eight dollars a month so if you go eight
so it's 96 right 9 times 12 96 so you go
96 times 3 million
is uh two oh [ __ ] a uh two point no
28 that's 28 no what what the [ __ ] no
you're not sorry sorry my [ __ ] screen
could jump around one two 288 million
288 million a month yeah that's assuming
eight dollars per month 12 months in a
year three million people pain but
there's not we know there's like a few
400 000. smoke this out smoke this out
do 12 months do 12 months what do you
come up with
no there is 12 months wait oh that's 12
months 288 yeah wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait I can't be
right that can't be right that can't be
right and the reason why I can't be
right is he's got to cover three billion
dollars you know this right he gave that
can't be he just said he he's the
smartest richest man in the world he
invented electricity Gabe Sanchez yeah
he invented electricity
let don't listen to me listen to me you
this cannot be correct because it he has
to have three billion dollars in the
revenue he just told us that this that
this driver thing is going to fix his
problem and let's let's also keep clear
why he needs this money he made a
purchase for a company at 54 20 per
share which equaled 44 billion where a
company that was probably valued at 12
billion he overpaid he took out a loan
of 13 billion that he has to pay this is
his [ __ ] Choice he took out a private
loan for 13 billion and has to pay a
million and a half in interest by next
year
he should have paid to get out of the
deal and right now now that he's in his
position he's in what he should do
before we go what he should do Gabe
Sanchez is he should hire Snoop Dogg as
the CEO and let Snoop Dogg run Twitter I
actually believe that would be fantastic
before we go though you have to play
just this one last part of the clip oh
is is it get better it gets better oh
yes all right let's talk about Break
Even let's listen I think we will be
about uh hopefully it's for roughly cash
flow break even that's what I expect for
next year
um
wait wait we just did the math yeah it
doesn't make it doesn't make sense but
then he but he goes I think he goes up a
little bit more on this Okay let's
listen but this this won't be quite this
will be difficult but but I think that's
that's where what will happen it's
roughly cash flow break even as opposed
to minus three billion ish
uh on on worth one billion of cash which
would be therefore dead
um so that's uh therefore dead he's he's
literally saying if we can't do this
Twitter is dead that's what he just said
right and if that one word remember yeah
let's look at the math here he says
Twitter has a billion dollars in cash
right now that's that's what they have
in the bank okay struggling he spent the
last five weeks cutting resources
cutting salaries wait wait wait wait put
this in perspective he has one billion
in cash he's admitting that right here
on the streets
how many billion did he sell a Tesla
stock to make this work three and a half
three point six Bill well total 26
billion so he sold 26 billion listen to
this folks he sold 26 billion dollars
billion with a B
to make this work and he only he only
gets a billion dollars of that lift and
Twitter so so let's let's let's listen
to the rest here okay
uh the reason for my actions that that
may seem sometimes uh
experience
odd or whatever uh it's because this is
not we have an emergency fire drill in
our hands that's the reason yeah you did
it uh I am like naturally capricious or
or at least aspirationally I'm not
naturally capricious
um so uh but but if if you sort of if
you say you're looking at it from my
standpoint and you're saying okay wow um
this company is is like like basically
you're in a plane
that is headed towards the ground at
high speed uh with the engines on fire
and the controls don't work
[Laughter]
oh Elon you are the greatest content
provider of the year right after Donald
Trump is [ __ ] fantastic what a
[ __ ] bonehead hey I I tweeted this I
don't know three or four days ago hey
[ __ ] put down the [ __ ] machine rehire
all your employees everyone need to do
that now well hey whatever you got to do
sell Tesla rehire all your employees
sell it to Pennies on the Dollar sell
Twitter Pennies on dollar rehire I hire
back all your employees let them run
that [ __ ] and you go pretend that you
invented electricity or some [ __ ] again
he's definitely gonna find himself and
remember tomorrow we don't or tomorrow
we will have a uh a bone out of the week
pole yeah but we're off Friday so we
won't have it but I can almost say for
certainty oh he's got this guy's gonna
yeah this guy's gonna be on it this
guy's gonna be all right everybody
thanks for joining us tomorrow to
tomorrow will be our last show of this
week we are on Friday and off Monday for
Christmas the Christmas holiday but
tomorrow I I hope we'll be bringing the
Christmas spirit oh yeah yeah we'll
figure out something to do for Christmas
right something something we'll figure
out something so everybody make sure
same time same place YouTube Twitter
twitch and the Midas touch Facebook page
Newton Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
tomorrow
until then Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon